okay hi everyone we are live for this
edition of book club okay so the good
news is it worked so it's actually we're
actually doing this is very exciting a
couple of shout outs thank you for every
from joining from Egeria jakarta toronto
indiana venezuela from the lake district
in the UK from the USA a employees in
the house how are you like us a a good
people are there the dakota potato peel
pie and literary society always nice to
see you guys the aspiration catalyst
business brilliance book club I love all
the book club names Toronto Philadelphia
Morocco I like Morocco I've been to
Marrakesh India Minnesota Bogota I love
this hello everyone and welcome to part
three of our book club thank you
everyone who joined in last week for
putting up with us with our type of
technical difficulties that we were
dealing with that we ended up on
Instagram if you didn't get part 1 or
part 2 of the book club
they are always available on YouTube
ok so it has been 10 years since start
with why came out and my publisher asked
me would I make a ten year anniversary
edition basically update it write a
little new stuff and so that means I
have to go read a book I haven't read in
like 8 or 9 years and I thought well if
I have to do it do it with some other
people too so we decided especially in
these kovat times to make a book club
and the whole idea of the book club is
not about reading the book it's about
doing something with each other it's
about doing something together so we
asked people to call friends call family
form book clubs read a section of the
book each week and each week we get
together and discuss the section so I
read my section I've been very good and
I have to say this was a really fun
section this really got into some of the
stuff that I really really love that you
can see is a springboard for so much
more of my
the work it's about belonging a lot
about trust the babysitter analogy I
forgotten about that I remember writing
it it's one of my favorite little
analogies about how trust forms that we
trust people who are like us who've come
from our neighborhoods that there's some
shared values and the analogy if you
remember was that if if there's somebody
from your neighborhood who wants to baby
you said your kid who's never babysat
them before or would you trust a
babysitter who's from far away even if
they've had training and they're from
far when you've never met them before
we're more likely to go with the person
from our neighborhood which is kind of
interesting I was talking with this with
somebody about this the other day
you know I'm I'm I live in New York but
I'm not friends with everybody in New
York that's crazy but if I go to say
Minnesota and I meet somebody from New
York I'm like hey I'm from New York and
we're like best friends and if I go on
vacation to France and I hear an
American accent and like hey where you
guys from you're from Minnesota I'm from
New York and we're best friends and it's
really kind of amazing how human beings
want we're so tribal we want to be
around people who are like us and a lot
of this chapter was about that I told
the story of Laurie Robinson Laurie
Robinson is really funny because in the
book I say she's a she's a brigadier
general Laurie just retired from the
military a year ago and at her
retirement she was the most senior
female leader in the history of the
United States military she is a
remarkable leader in fact you know what
what might be fun I should do a I should
do a YouTube live interview with her
I'll do that she's great I would love
for you guys to meet Laurie Robinson and
she's she's this kind of leader who is
so devoted to her cause whenever you
whenever I interact with her she always
talked about her kids what she means is
those in her charge those in her command
and no matter how senior she got she
would always refer to to the folks that
she was responsible for is my kids and
you could tell that she had deep love
and this you can see that this is what
drives her and this is what made her
such a great leader and it's why people
it's why she commanded such great trust
it wasn't just because she was good
her job it's because she had absolute
love and care for the people that she
did her job for she always believed that
she was in service to those who served
others the other thing that this section
touched on the law of diffusion of
innovations now I can't stress enough
the importance of this law of diffusion
I for me it's like a religion I built my
whole career on it when I first read
about the law of diffusion and realized
that if I wanted to if I wanted I had
these ideas that I believed had value in
the world if I wanted many many people
to learn about them I realized I wasn't
gonna aim my efforts at the majority I
needed to talk to the the innovators and
the early adopters I needed to make a
tipping point and a lot of people I
don't even think they know this that
that my work has spread without
marketing and advertising you know I
don't have a publicist we sort of
everything's been mostly organic even
the spread of the TED talk was organic
most of the people who knew about my my
who who seen that TED talk weren't
tedsters they were they were forwarded
that TED talk by somebody else and so
I'll give you an example of how the law
of diffusion works in practical terms
when I learned my why and I knew that I
owned I wanted to do business with
people who believed what I believed not
just people who needed what I have but
people who believed what I believed I
remember in the early days I didn't have
two pennies to rub together I was living
paycheck to paycheck I need every
consulting gig I could get just to pay
my bills and I remember my phone rang
somebody had heard about me from someone
else and almost you know immediately he
said I've heard about your work this is
what he said
I remember this call I even remember
where I was walking he said convince me
why I should hire you and I said don't
because the minute somebody says
convince me why I should hire them he's
asking me to sell to him he's asked me
to give him all the rational reasons I'm
looking for people who were inspired to
do business so because if he says
convince me why I should hire you that
means every suggestion or piece of
advice I have he's gonna say convince me
why I should listen that's not my
business my business is not the
convincing business I'm in the business
of offering
respective do or don't do it I would
rather make less money and do business
with someone who goes you know you're
onto something here I don't think you
have it all right but I think what
you're doing is I think you're onto
something those are the people I wanted
to do business with and so even in the
early days I tried to be super selective
which again trying to manage making
living and and and creating a tipping
point but I tried as best as I could to
only do business with people who
believed what I believed those early
adopters because what happened was they
would introduce me to other people they
would say there's someone I need you to
meet and that's how things would spread
things spread very quickly and I was the
same person all I did was stop talking
about what I do and started talking
about what I believed I started talking
about why I do what I do I used to joke
that the best test was the test of
sitting next to someone on a plane if we
ever get to do that again when somebody
turns to you and asks that dreaded
question what do you do well I mean
before I discovered the concept of why I
would have said I'm a marketing
consultant and I have these clients and
oh what a snooze right sell sell sell
what what what what what but after I
learned about the why after many truck
many efforts of trial and error I would
say to people I teach leaders and
organizations how to inspire people now
if they believe what I believe they
would hear different words right so if
they believe what I believe they would
say inspiration huh that's really cool
and we'd be talking about my work for
the next two hours if they didn't
believe what I believed they said what
kind of companies and it was so
fascinating how in one sentence I could
learn whether they they were people who
were early adopters or not if they were
if they were believed what I believed so
I cannot stress the importance and the
value of the law of diffusion for
spreading our ideas and finding people
who are more likely to champion our work
than simply trying to convince people to
buy from us so this this was a this
chapter was chock-full of all of my
favorite stories the Wright brothers
Shackleton Lori Robinson Martin Luther
King I mean it was really as it was I so
enjoyed this chapter
personally because the section rather
because it was all my favorite stories
so with that oh yes
with that let's talk about some of your
questions okay
let's see what we have here can't scroll
good one Corliss and Diana yes so after
you know your why how do you manage
crisis or complex situations so a why is
a foundation upon which we can it's a
lens right so and the the purpose of the
lenses it's get us away from focusing on
what so for example let's talk let's
let's this is how I'm using my why to
manage this very crisis so what do I do
right I write books and I give speeches
right that's a large part of what I do
you do other stuff too but that's that's
a large part of what I do okay
so there's no way I can just write a
book I need an idea so that's not
happening and the idea of giving public
speeches right now
can't do it and so if I focus on what
I'm gonna all I'm gonna focus is like
how am I gonna do more speeches online
how can I do more speeches for kovat
right
during Kovan times and the problem is my
thinking will get very very narrow
because I can only think about trying to
do what I'm doing through a new media
that that's it but that's not what we've
done we've leaned back and said okay are
wise to inspire people to do the things
that inspire them that's why we do what
we do and we have this vision to create
this world in which the vast majority of
people wake up every single morning
inspired feel safe wherever they are and
end the day fulfilled by the work that
they do that's the world we're trying to
create so what are the ways that we can
do that if we were starting from scratch
if there's no such thing as a speech and
so what we've done is we've done like
months worth of work in like two weeks
it's kind of amazing
so next week at some point we're gonna
be launching all of this new course work
that we've come up with
to help people get through these times
it's all relevant to right now this is
this is amazing that we put this
together in these two weeks in fact one
of the things we've done who's gonna
tell you guys later is a little
surprised but it's coming up now we are
doing a beta test of jumpstart your why
that launches when does it launch what
is it like oh it's live now look at us
okay so it's only four people for book
club so we're not making any public
announcements about this yet because
it's a beta it's only four people for
book club we have a hundred slots if you
want to learn your why we've we've
figured out a way to do a jump start
your why it's a two-hour workshop that
you can learn your why you can you can
go through the whole thing if you go to
where is it Simon Singh Kham no no if
you look at the chat there'll be a link
in the chat we'll give you a special
link to jumpstart away we only have a
hundred seats and because we know that
these are difficult times the model that
we've done is pay what you can so
whatever you want to pay you can pay
zero you can whatever you want pay what
you can is the pricing model first
hundred people get to do jump start your
Y with one of our fantastic fantastic
brilliant facilitators from our team
Steve he's wonderful so there's that
okay let's do it for the money bonus is
that my wife oh great question so this
comes from the Y believe is book club
that's in Belgium I like this one this
is an international book club this one's
in USA Italy Germany and Belgium that I
love this it's a it's a whole group of
you so Vincent from the why believers
book club asked I'd like to say that I
like to win that's how I describe myself
that's what drives me I don't do it for
the money or for the bonus is that my
why Vincent it is not winning is a
result
and so we all like the win it feels good
to everybody and the problem with doing
something for the win though it's
motivating it's not inspiring is because
after you do it's this that's dopamine
you get a hit of dopamine from winning
right so you do it once you want to do
it again and we want to do it again what
happens if you go through a whole string
where you don't win do you stay inspired
remember winning as a result inspiration
is an input winning is an output and so
the question is what is it it's and it's
not just winning everything are you that
competitive that you would if you're so
driven to win would you trip people and
and cheat so you can win that's the
problem with being only motivated to the
win so the question is is that the
reason your friends love you because you
just like to win of course not
and our why is the value we give to the
world that is bigger than the win more
than the win and may drive us even when
we're not winning and keep us inspired
regardless of the outcome and it's the
reason our friends love us it's the
reason our colleagues relevance it's the
reason our clients and customers love us
so your friends don't love you because
you're a winner your friends love you
because you offer some value to them in
their lives that's where you that's
where you want to go searching let's
look at another question here we have
[Music]
Lowell Applebaum yes so the question was
is finding those who believe in your
work how do you stay focused only doing
business with people who believe you
believe without looking like an
egotistical bastard great question
well the question is are you an
egotistical bastard what I found was
that when I talked to people who who
didn't believe what I believed
I never you know did people think I was
an egotistical bastard they think I was
arrogant I mean I guess there was some
of it but but the reality was it was the
way they treated me that made it easy to
say no
you know because they were they were not
about working together to advance
something together they were about what
can you give me and and and I wasn't
like high and mighty about it I wasn't
just like I only do business with people
who believe what I believe the way I
would turn people down is instead of
saying I don't think you're right for me
I would say I don't think I'm the right
guy for you is what I would say if I got
a sense that this was gonna be a
difficult relationship or that they were
interested in something very different I
would say I don't think I'm the right
the right person for you you have to
understand I'm an idealist I'm driven to
build this world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired feel safe wherever they
are and end the day fulfilled by the
work that they do and I'm really looking
to work with clients where we are
working together to advance this common
cause you do what you do I do what I do
and I just don't think I'm the right guy
for you is how it would go across did I
make mistakes and get it wrong sometimes
of course of course sometimes I said yes
to the wrong people and probably said no
to the right people but unbalanced it
was pretty good because I could see how
my career changed trajectory trajectory
I can't get that word out trajectory I
can't now it sounds silly
it's like celery celery celery celery it
change trajectory and the only thing I
started doing was being more selective
because again I was the same idiot I
didn't have a new skill set I just
learned how to put my why front and
foremost but no I think if if if you
really make it about looking for
partners to help advance common cause it
really is quite humbling I think for
most people are engaged with you let's
get another question can you give more
examples of service services companies
coaches teachers consultants and they're
wise and they're what's so thank you
Lisa for that so if you're a coach or
your service well first of all I'm a
that's what I was doing I was offering
consulting I was a services person but
really it's what what so many people in
the service world do is they they talk
about the value in generic terms like
they talk about the value of coach
that's great like it's it's all true but
that's just a coach and then when and
the problem is is when you ask to
distinguish yourself you talk about your
years of experience or your schooling or
how many clients you have or how you've
helped people which is all valuable but
remember the goal in the circle is about
the order of the information it's not
that any information is not relevant
it's the order of the information and we
if you're a coach the question is is
what was so what was so important for
you that you decided to become a coach
what was so important that it was worth
taking the risk to do something with an
overwhelming chance of failure that
you're gonna be slogging it what was so
important for you to become a coach and
very often the best stories of when it's
a personal story that somebody talks
about how I was struggling with
something and I hired a coach and I
couldn't believe the the impact and I
was so profoundly moved by the impact
they had on me I decided that I wanted
to share that impact with others now do
you see it's not about the coaching it's
about having a profound positive impact
in the lives of others and so it has to
be true though you don't it to be some
generic story about the value of
coaching it's it's like I talked to
pharmaceutical people and I'm like so
why do you do what you do they're like
well we want to get people healthy well
that's what we care about or anybody or
hospitals you know it doesn't matter who
and I'm like well that's the why for the
industry it's not the why for your
organization it doesn't distinguish you
that's that's that's the why for every
everything and anything in health care
but that doesn't distinguish the
cultures of to hospitals or to
pharmaceutical companies and yet we know
those cultures are different so it's
really about talking about the vision
you have or your origin story remember a
wise an origin story so you can talk
about why you did this for yourself and
why you want to do it further so you can
talking about historical examples is a
good trick why you got into it in the
first place middle-earth book club some
junior are a Tolkien stories
play the a leader who earns trust and a
self trust play a role do people need to
trust themselves in order to discern
confidence for Samaritans right so the
question is let's break those down I'll
probably forget them
let's take a look lips so the question
was what which one was it where is it
you just handed me a piece of paper but
I don't know where it is
middle-earth book club thank you what
role does personality play in being a
leader who earns trust
well the personality part how big your
personality is see think about it in
terms of relationships like you go on a
date and someone has a big personality
that's very appealing I mean there's no
question about it but the more time you
spend with them you realize it's just
bluster were you going to date with
somebody who's a little bit quiet maybe
a little bit socially awkward but you
get along with them and you like them
and you spend more time with them and
you realize they're a really good person
so personality can be appealing at the
beginning but at the end of the day it's
about integrity Trust works the same way
whether we're talking about professional
relationships with with brands or with
each other so think about how we build
trust with each other it's very
difficult to build trust overnight
we can build trust quicker with some
people than others that definitely
happens but deep deep trust requires
time and the more time you get the
deeper the trust grows so so a
personality can can can be inviting but
it's not essential but you can we should
also sometimes be suspicious of people
who I mean like salespeople for example
or con artists not equating the two
notic waiting the two just saying that
what a confidence artist does is they
know the tricks to say things to us to
get us to trust them except it's not
real sales people good sales people it's
genuine and they really want to help us
but a smarmy salesperson salesperson who
just wants to make the sale and doesn't
care about us they all say anything they
need to say to to to try to engender
trust but all of these things fall apart
in time and then the second part of your
question is does self trust play a role
so the difference between I think
I think confidence always plays a role
and I there's healthy ego and unhealthy
ego healthy ego is believing I'm good
unhealthy ego is believing I'm better
than you and I think all the best
leaders I've met they have they they
they definitely believe in themselves
but they don't believe that they're
they're better than other people they
think other people have great ideas they
think other people is smart they think
other people can teach them they're just
confident in what they know and and many
of them are very stubborn about their
visions they're there they really want
to build their visions and I'm pretty
stubborn about mine you know that that
creating a world that's inspired safe
and fulfilled I'm I'm pretty stubborn
about getting there and everything from
the people we hire to the marketing
decisions we make to the the the the the
the the the products we might might
offer you know every course that you're
gonna see that we're gonna offer in in
the in the next week where this
jumpstart your why always always always
has to go towards building that that
vision because because I'm stubborn got
a little bit of good news less bad news
which is the jump start your Y class is
sold out so thank you for everybody who
signed up don't worry it's a beta we're
testing it out with these first hundred
people there all the early adopters law
of diffusion always start with the early
adopters always testing testing things
that with the early adopters which is
why we started in book club once we get
all the kinks out we figure out what's
going on we will make it readily
available to many many more people so
thank you to everyone who joined and I
hope you enjoy it please give us lots of
feedback okay another question John
McCain from the o2 campus book club 127
members in this book club oh my god I
love it
127 members love you guys during this
current pandemic have you seen any
countries or governments who are
demonstrating their Y through their
leadership yes
Germany pretty good New Zealand pretty
good New Zealand has been fantastic app
so actually there was a
just an article I think it was in Forbes
magazine this week that basically said
the countries that have been the best at
treating the pandemic and addressing the
pandemic were all female leaders I think
there's a reason for that
I think female leaders tend to bring
empathy out front first in other words
when making the decision do we act soon
to protect people even though it's gonna
cost us in the short term in the economy
they for them it was an easy choice of
course you do
of course you do I think traditionally
men sort of like well let's wait and see
because we don't I like we don't to lose
the money and hurt they kind of mean
let's let's just wait and see so so I
think the the the this wonderful article
in Forbes magazine about the the
countries that were that are run by
female leaders almost to a tee got out
in front of this and and with great with
great positive effect again I've said
this before it's not that you know if
you think about traditional female
characteristics things like empathy
maternal instinct patience you think
about traditional male characteristics
like aggression decisiveness it's not
that we need more female leaders in the
world it's that we need more leaders
that act like females women just happen
to be better at that so we need more
empathy from all leaders we need more
patience from all leaders and we need
more leaders to prioritize human beings
over numbers let's see what we have yeah
the giraffe book club yes oh my god you
just made me feel bad so the giraffe
book club from Germany as what is TiVo
you just basically what you pointed out
was my book is 10 years old and there
are some technologies in there that no
longer exist
TiVo what I should either write a full
description in the updated version or
take it out I like the story though so
I'll probably write a full description
TiVo was the forerunner for DVR for
digital recorders you know what a DVR is
right I'm not as I'm not that old right
we do know what DVRs are okay
so TiVo was the was one of the pioneers
it was the probably one of the
pioneering companies that invented DVR
and when they introduced their product
years ago a lot of years ago it was the
best product on the market and then they
failed and they didn't fail because the
product was wasn't good they failed
because they didn't know how to talk
about what they believed they can only
you know this is the problem with
companies that are run by engineers
engineers are enamored by what the
insides of the engineering and they want
to tell everybody about the engineering
and the and and the things that it does
and yet that's not what people want the
famous story I don't it's not I don't
know if it didn't start with why it's
definitely not we haven't read it yet if
it is or was it yeah it was yes it was
in the last section I talk about
creative versus the apples iPod creative
invented the mp3 player in the early
days of mp3s and it was run by a company
of engineers so the way they marketed it
is they said a five gigabyte mp3 player
and then Apple came out with the iPod
and said a thousand songs in your pocket
do you want a five gigabyte mp3 player
would you want a thousand songs in your
pocket
super easy decision so yeah that was why
TiVo failed but TiVo it was the
originator and pioneer of digital video
recorders which are now built into our
set-top boxes everywhere so thank you
giraffe booklet yes influencer from the
JLA book club can we teach someone to be
an influencer thank you very much for
that question an influencer can you
teach someone to be an influencer I
think you can teach let's go with yes
you can teach someone to start with why
you can teach someone to to practice
what they preach you can teach someone
to obey the law of diffusion of
innovations and if they start with why
and they are working to appeal and
attract the early adopters what happens
is they gain influence and they're
gaining influence not necessarily
because of just them it's because of the
hordes of people who believe what they
believe it goes back to that wonderful
Martin Luther
example in in the section that we just
read how many people showed up on the
mall in Washington DC for dr. King zero
they showed up for themselves and that's
what being an influencer is all about I
think I think there's a and I think
human beings are a little bit like
products which is there are there are
there are fads and there are things that
last so I think there are some people
who are influencers for now just like
the hula hoop was a thing for a little
bit you know or wacky wall Walker x' or
Rubik's cubes or all of these fads that
all died away for the most part I think
there are some people like that which is
they have their little pop they have
their little 15 minutes of fame they
have some influence and then they
disappear because it wasn't really based
on something a solid foundation remember
a why is the solid foundation that's
what it is we that we thought the what
was appealing which gave them temporary
influence but to have long-lasting
influence to to really continue to to
deliver value to people and and have
people want to tune in year after year
after year after year there has to be a
solid foundation based on values and
based on cause Dylan Smith okay so the
question was in Southwest Airlines Herb
Kelleher he instinctively knew that he
had to create an environment which
people felt cared for as did Gordon
Bethune if you work in a company that
management doesn't let you know that you
that you matter and you don't feel cared
for how do you let them know well
unfortunately no number of anonymously
sent books will change their minds or
change their behavior but please keep
trying the the the the we cannot change
that which we cannot change and this is
good old-fashioned Viktor Frankl stuff
you know that should be our next book
club book you know man's search for
meaning by Viktor Frankl essential
reading for the human race as far as I'm
concerned but Viktor Frank
said that we cannot control the world
around us we can only control our
attitude and if we cannot change the
circumstances the only thing we can do
is change ourselves and so it we cannot
we cannot change the way management
leads but we can change the way we lead
and so the option there is to be the
leader you wish you had instead of
trying to bang on management's door and
say we don't feel cared for care for the
people around us and what you start to
see is you start to see a groundswell
because now the popular leaders the
leaders with the most influence become
these ones who've devoted themselves to
being the leaders they wish they had
now there's also safety in numbers the
more that these these pockets of great
leadership grow those groups become
higher performing they have higher
morale fewer people quit few people are
fired and those 10 those teams tend to
be higher performing which means
management either leaves you alone or if
they're curious they come and say what
are you doing and you say interestingly
we're taking care of our people remember
there's a lot of senior people in big
companies these days that practice very
old-fashioned leadership they practice
finite minded leadership they practice
the leadership style that was perfect in
the 80s and 90s okay boomer and so you
know are they gonna change their tricks
late in age I mean they could some of
the curious ones might but the reality
is I would rather we build a solid
foundation and prepare for when they
eventually leave the company infinite
mindset we'll get to that another day
yes Nick Miller yes
adapted in in my business okay okay so
how do you find the early adopters in a
mature business in which your market
well the good news is an early adopter
is as based on values and it doesn't
matter how much sure the market is it's
based on your ability to talk about what
you believe and so even in mature
markets if you start talking about what
you believe the ones in in who are out
there are going to be more drawn to you
you could you can do it inside companies
too like you can go to large companies
that are dysfunctional I've worked with
some large dysfunctional companies and
we need the early adopters inside the
company to affect to affect cultural
change and so there's one organization
that I'm thinking of as a very very
large sprawling bureaucrat at
old-fashioned organizations that had
lost its identity I mean all that all
the things you expect to hear people
were you know there were pockets of
greatness but as an organization it was
it was really kind of blah but there are
a lot of people who believed in the
founding purpose of that organization
remember a why is an origin story and so
what we did was I used my bully pulpit
to remind people of the history of the
organization and why it was formed and
we found that that we found other
leaders who would go give that same talk
at the beginning of meetings and remind
people they would and they would start
meetings like this let me let me tell
you guys why I love this company love
emotional not like limbic like is
rational I like the product I like the
people I get paid well I like this
company love this company emotional why
based right and so we'd find these
people who are really connected to the
to the cause of the company and they'd
say let me tell you why I love this
company and they were telling they would
tell it a story from the past
remember origin stories and people would
come up to us and say I really liked
what you said those are the early
adopters they made themselves known to
us as soon as we as soon as we put out
the message they would come to us after
meetings and say I really liked what you
said that I wish that I that's what I
want this company to be more like again
and we were like okay we need you start
telling this story start telling people
why you love this company too so even if
we didn't have the why fully formed we
could still find the early
wherever they were so mature or immature
does not matter this is about finding
people who believe what you believe and
they are everywhere all the time and
it's much easier to find them if we talk
about what we believe and then they just
show up they make themselves known to us
ok let's do another one
what we have here we did middle-earth
book club Steph and Friends hi Stefan
friends how do why people find their hi
people how people outside their friends
and family network Stefan friends have
been reading ahead this is from a future
chapter but that's ok we'll we'll answer
it now so how do you find your or how
people how to why people find their how
people outside of their friends and
family network well first of all it's
predicated on belief again which is
those why people the the why people get
really good at talking about what they
believe but they know that they need
help to build it they might be able to
see the forest for the trees but they
can't see their way through the forest
and what ends up happening is you'll
find people who come and say I was
really inspired by your work and you get
to know them and you find out their
skill sets and what I love how people
sometimes are insecure because they
don't have big ideas they're not the big
idea people but how people need to be
really confident in the fact that they
are so good at taking other people's big
ideas and making them come to life
because I can tell you I'm a why guy I
would be doing none of this if it
weren't for a team even just this book
club there was a small group of
wonderful people who helped make this
happen so yeah find the people who want
to help you build it like literally
they'll come up to you and say I love
what you're doing can I help you build
it they'll use the word build they'll
use how words in describing their desire
to be a part of what you are talking
about what you're promoting ok question
from the Fox force 6 I assume that's
because there's six of you how within
the hiring process can you screen for
why when the typical hiring process is
dance ain't that the truth when we go
through a hiring process we're trying to
sell how great we are they're trying to
sell how great they are their company is
you know what's your biggest weakness
well my biggest weakness is I'm a
perfectionist yeah we both try and put
on our best show so that will appeal to
each other so how can you screen for
for--why when you're hiring so you can
do it both ways by the way both as the
higher and the higher e if you're the
interviewer if you're being interviewed
if you're looking for a job one of my
favorite questions that I would love to
ask when I was being interviewed is I
would ask the aged person the HR person
do you love your job and I had to sit
there and listen and wait and it was
amazing in in some of the companies that
weren't based on why everybody I
interviewed with nobody said yes they
said oh yeah I really like my job and
I'm like I would start to pay attention
I wanted people who loved their jobs I
would come flat out and ask what's the
vision of the company and you can listen
are they articulate in the vision if you
ask multiple people do they all give you
the same answer
what's this company's cause what do you
stand for what are you hoping to build
it's bigger than the money you make and
if everybody gave me the same answer
then it's clear but I can't tell you how
many times I would ask this and you get
like ten different answers from 10
different people I think it's also
really important when we interview that
we have to remember that we're not
working for a company we're working for
people and it's more important to work
for a great leader than it is to work
for a great company I worked at some ok
companies but I had some fantastic
leaders early in my career and I
remember when I was junior in my career
and you know some HR person would
interview me to say what are you looking
for I always say I'm looking what I'm
looking for is probably a little bit
like looking for love but I'm looking
for a mentor and I was kept looking for
a boss that I knew that I believed in
and who got a kick out of me and wanted
to help foster my career and sometimes
that was more important so I came up
through the marketing and advertising
world most of the people in my in my
career they only cared about what
account they were gonna work on they
wanted glamorous accounts I work for
coca-cola or American Express or Nike or
whatever glamorous accounts I worked on
some pretty crummy accounts from an
advertising standpoint but
because I was way more interested in who
I worked for then what account I worked
on so again that that really helped me
in my career I learned a lot about
leadership from that now if you're the
interviewer interviewing people same
thing so you can ask something so tell
me what you stand for tell me what you
hope to advance in your life bigger than
the money you make and see if people
articulate or articulate or my favorite
story is tell me tell me a story of
something you did in your career that
you absolutely loved being a part of one
of my favorite questions tell me a story
of something you did in your career that
you absolutely loved being a part of
whether it's commercially successful or
not and the story that somebody will
tell is gonna be something emotional I'm
using the word love and it's gonna be
based on their wine you're gonna find
out a lot about them from that question
about who they are not just what they
can do does that help the why believers
book club true so people don't buy what
you do they buy why you do it
then it and and I get accused of this a
lot it's all fine and good for you know
packaged goods or you know glamorous
products but no that's not the case you
can if you're a component supplier it
still matters I there's a I did there
was a large I wonder if I'm allowed to
talk about it I mean it was a division
of General Electric yeah who cares we
can talk about GE who cares so as I did
some work a long time ago with a
division of GE they eventually sold it
up it was called GE silicones and
basically it was an ingredient silicones
is an ingredient many many many things
from cosmetics to the tiles on the Space
Shuttle it's an ingredient and then an
ER agree ingredient and it was largely a
commodity so not only was it an
ingredient was a commodity which is even
worse you know the all the product was
basically the same from all the
suppliers and GE wanted us to
investigate they wanted us better
understand loyalty so they could because
the way that GE defined loyalty was
who spent the most money with us that's
that's how they define loyalty so they
gave all of the extra value-added the
special phone numbers the the scientific
you know the scientists to help you
solve your problems whatever it was all
the list of value add they gave it to
the people who spent the most money
that's how they defined it defined loyal
so we went and did some research we
interviewed a ton of customers and
interviewed all sorts of people and we
found out that there were people who was
spending a ton of money who didn't care
about any of the value add basically if
the price was the cheapest and GE had
the quantity of product they wanted they
bought it from GE and if somebody else
had a better price they bought it from
somebody else in other words they were
gonna spend money with GE no matter what
regardless but then we found this whole
group of customers that when GE screwed
up the order or GE was more expensive
they continued to business do business
with GE in other words there was loyalty
now in this case they weren't mrs.
Hurley Laura for the company they were
loyal to the person they were probably
loyal to the whoever their sales person
was in other words they weren't just
paying the cheapest price even though
they could go somewhere else so even in
b2b usually goes down to the sales
person but it doesn't have to can go to
the company level a great company
barry-wehmiller one of my favorite
examples to talk about that I wrote
about in leaders at last
they make big machines and their
customers are very loyal to them because
of the kinds of company they are and
people want to do business with people
like them so is it a rule of course not
and some people just want to do business
based on the numbers but the the buyers
are the weak companies they're the
strong companies would rather do
business with suppliers that meet their
values a great great great example is
the Container Store The Container Store
worked very hard not only to do business
with suppliers who meet their values but
also to look after their suppliers just
like their suppliers looked after them
and they didn't always get the cheapest
prices and they didn't always get they
could you know they could they could
shop around but their quality of the
relationships between their suppliers
and and and The Container Store is what
helped The Container Store not only be
so successful but whether hard times
like like recession because they work
together with their suppliers so yes yes
yes yes yes it still works in b2b let's
see what else
you have here oh this is a good one I'll
get to you just one okay I don't want to
do this question okay I'll go first
thanks a Wilma a Wilma Ventura asks can
your professional y be different from
your personal why can you prefer can
your professional Y change based on your
role ah thank you for asking this
question thank you for asking this
question
you only have one why there is no such
thing as a personal y and a professional
why you are who you are and the reason
your friends love you is the exact same
reason your colleagues and your
customers and your clients love you it's
because of you and if you're acting
differently in one of those two places
than in one of those two places you're
lying
there's only one Y and the opportunities
to bring your Y to life personally
remember it's not about what you do so
my Y is to inspire people so how do I
show up as a friend to inspire people
how do I show up as a as a as a
colleague to inspire people I'm gonna
say different things but ultimately I
have to bring my Y to life in different
products those products our friend might
those products our leader those products
our colleague those predix or brother
and son and uncle and all of these
places these are different products
these are different things that I do
that I have to bring my Y to life so you
only have one Y and your Y never changes
your whole life regardless of the role
you play the opportunity your life
affords you is is to bring your is all
the choices you can make to bring your Y
to life so the question is is what
you're doing and why you're doing it
consistent because only when why how and
what are in perfect balance do we know
who you are people that people tell me
all that for years people's I forgot the
who know I didn't who is the sum total
of Y how and what when you know what you
believe and you follow your values and
what you do reflects what you believe in
your values then we know who you are
those things are out of order
or they or you violate those things
people say it's like I don't know who
you are anymore you have one y your Y
never changes just like a company our
personal Y is an origin story it's where
we come from it's who we are it's how we
were raised and the rest
our lives our opportunities to live in
balance or not okay what was that other
question you had for me let's see what
else I have here but Sonia in Munich it
mentioned how to mean trust in in the
current in the current climate when
difficult decisions are being made and
layoffs are being done not to meet
arbitrary financial projections but but
it's existential now it's about staying
alive and and in laying people off is
not inherently immoral it's how we do it
that is where our values come to bear um
I'll give you an example I have a friend
who was laid off she works for a company
of 35 people they love it they laid off
22 people it's the only way they guess
they decided it was the only way they
could survive we can debate whether
that's true or not but that's what they
did they did had they light up 22 out of
35 people here's how they did it they
called everybody up and it was literally
a twenty second phone call that said
yeah you sorry were laying you off you
don't have a job anymore
and regardless of how long they worked
there everybody got zero severance and
worse the people who kept their jobs
they didn't even tell them that they
just laid off twenty two people so a
friend of mine got a call from her
colleague saying hey I need you to do
something for me she's like oh no I
don't work there anymore she didn't even
know that is absolutely awful the way to
do it the question that the the question
is is how do we help people land on
their feet as best we can how do we help
people equip them to find new jobs it's
it's it's a it's if it's anything other
than gut-wrenching then it's probably
too soon it's the most most most
difficult decision to make
and that's how it should be and we
should have exhausted other
possibilities first you know rather cut
salaries first across-the-board better
we should all suffer a little than
everything any of us should have to
suffer a lot
but in some cases there were there are
companies that's just they don't exist
anymore but I hope people explore new
ways of doing things there's a
restaurant in New York called rez Dora
it's a great restaurant it's only been
open about nine or ten months and when
this came down the pike I mean you can
imagine a brand new restaurant they're
gonna be put out of business they're not
that people don't even know who they are
yet but what the owner stefano did is
instead of laying off the people who do
that he doesn't need anymore he doesn't
need waiters and waitresses anymore he
decided to change their jobs and this is
where I think opportunity lies in crisis
which is we can find new jobs and we can
make new jobs and he equipped his
company to start doing deliveries they
never did deliveries before it's a
fine-dining restaurant why would they do
deliveries and so the people who used to
be waiters and waitresses we're now
packaging food and organizing orders
they had different jobs and so we're
finding that in our company as well
which is we're we're doing all of this
online learning stuff that's starting
next week you the hundred of you who
signed up thank you thank you thank you
you're gonna experience our first class
like this is our first live webinar ever
and people who never have done this are
going to be doing this and we have all
these new jobs and we're asking people
to step up and challenge themselves to
do these new jobs so I hope the
companies that are that that are
exploring where else try other things
first but yeah there's a way to do it we
can treat people with dignity even if
it's even if we have to let them go what
else we have and helping them figure out
like helping them figure out the
resources you know the worst thing we
can do is tell somebody that they're
done and then leave them to their own
devices to figure out how they get
unemployment benefits like we as
companies can can help them land on
their feet that reduces the stress
tremendously to let them know that
there's that there are options anyway
you get the idea it's it hurts yes
[Music]
[Music]
okay so from the get going book club in
India you know this is an organic thing
when we use the law of diffusion of
innovations thank you very much for the
question
it's a it takes time for the law of
diffusion to work not always that's the
kind of amazing thing about it so you
know it could go quickly it could go
slowly this is this is what it we this
is a different book but the infinite
mindset is trusting in the unknown and
and one of the things you have to do
with the law of diffusion the reason
most companies won't use the law of
diffusion is because most companies want
to see they want to hit a specific goal
by a specific timeframe they want to hit
a certain number at the end of the year
and if you embrace the law of diffusion
it 100% works except I don't know how
quickly it works and so it's the same
it's the same thing of like exercise
right like if you work out every single
day for 20 minutes a hundred percent
you'll get into shape how long does it
take I don't know
quicker for some people slower for other
people a hundred percent it works 100%
it works I just don't know how long and
so you know people would rather get
surgery or take pills or something
because they can get hit results by a
certain time as opposed to doing the
hard steady work of working out we're
eating healthy or any other thing like
that
this is exactly the same which is it a
hundred percent works but and sometimes
it happens quickly and sometimes it
happens slowly but I can't tell you how
long it takes so just from my personal
experience how long did it take for me
for the law of diffusion to start going
so I can I actually know these dates I
started talking publicly about the
logged about start with why and I knew
about the law of diffusion I had already
embraced it and I started talking about
it in January of what are we in 2020
2006 jennie-o 2006 oh it's been a while
Jan of 2006 is when I first started
talking about this thing called the why
and I decided that I was only gonna I
was gonna start talking about the why
that when people said what do you do is
when I tell them what I believed first I
made all these decisions and I started
practicing and it took me a while it
took me like
80 or 100 times on how to do this I you
know when I first started people looked
at me like I was crazy I still do and I
started making those very difficult
decisions saying no to people and yes to
others I started being more discerning
within six months I think it was by
August yeah so eight months within eight
months I was standing in the Pentagon
presenting this concept of start with y2
this to the chief of staff and the
Secretary of the Air Force eight months
is all it took and it proof I mean like
things started going crazy because what
I started doing was talking about what I
believed to everyone anyone who asked
I'm a great believer in sharing your
ideas all the time because you never
know who's sitting at the table I know
people who's so afraid of sharing their
ideas in case somebody steals their
ideas I'll tell you a funny story I was
at a I was at a party once and I was
talking to someone I met at the party
and I said what do you do and she told
me what she does she says but I'm also
writing a screenplay I said fantastic
what's it about and she said I'm not
telling you I said well why not
she goes because you'll steal my idea
I'm like first of all I'm not a
screenwriter and second of all I'm busy
I'm not gonna write a screenplay but
tell me what your idea is and she said
no so I to this day I have no idea what
the the idea is and I don't know if it
got made or not but the problem is is I
can't help her if she had said well I
had this amazing idea about you know
this that the other I would be like oh
my god I know the producer of this show
he would love that let me introduce you
and so I took the risk to share my ideas
early early on because at the end of the
day the only people who steal ideas the
people who don't have them ideas people
you know yes my ideas have been stolen
I'll come up with more you know ideas
people you have more ideas and so and so
I would talk about my ideas all the time
every meeting everywhere I went people
said so what are you working on these
days I would tell them and and what
starts to happen is the people in the
room who come up they would come up to
me afterwards and say there's someone I
need you to meet that that's how my
whole career spread is somebody who
believed what I believed said there's
someone I want you to meet
and it was always a good meeting because
they knew what they believed they now
knew what I believed they were an old
friend I was somebody new and they would
connect us and we would always get along
because we were being put together based
on our why not based on what we do and
so the relationships were better and the
the quality of the relationships were
more efficient and we I was able to
build trust quicker and so things just
moved quicker so I had one meeting at
the Pentagon prior it worked the same
way I was in a meeting I said what I
believed somebody happened to be a part
of the the Air Force he said can you
come to the Pentagon I've never been to
the Pentagon in my life and like yes yes
yes he invited me to give a little
workshop on the Golden Circle to a few
people in the room there was one person
in the room who said I work for the
chief of staff can you come present this
to him it was only two meetings that led
to that experience because I obsessively
talked about what I believed and always
the people who came up to me after the
meetings were the most important ones I
think we have time for one more question
you know we said we can do this for like
half an hour 45 minutes and so much more
fun to do it for an hour
probably do it for longer what's this
one say this is the PRC book club in
Ontario the professional Resource Center
book club
hello PRC book club our book club is
growing and now consists of 10 Eva
Tiffany pasa
Kim KT Juliana Marian
Chenoa Connie's and and Corey well hello
everyone how do you generate interview
questions that support people to
demonstrate their why so you can know
the person you're hiring oh we talked
about this one already
um tell a story of something you've done
in your career that that you love doing
a part of that's a good one so I think
we'll do one more for fab pharmacists
gonna guess there's four of you you're
all pharmacists and you're all fabulous
I like this one this is a good what if
your company clearly communicates it's
why but you don't see things happening
in the company that reflect there why
well unfortunately when I first started
down this path
all those years ago starting talking
about why and purpose inside companies I
was considered a heretic nobody talked
about purpose inside companies that was
like hippie dippie stuff now it's common
for companies to talk about purpose and
companies in fact every company has a
purpose statement on their website but
the problem is is it real or is it
marketing and so the first question I
would ask is the company's purpose might
be clearly articulated is it real or is
it marketing do they say it because they
actually believe it or do they say it
because it's they kind of have to do it
these days and so we're discerning
remember we talked about this before
about charisma and personality well it
depends do you actually believe the
things you're saying so some companies
are saying things that they don't
actually believe that's a problem now
can you hold the company accountable to
it absolutely the fact that they said it
out loud makes it fun so then in a
meeting somebody says we're gonna do X
and we can raise our head and say just a
quick question so on our website and in
the meeting you talk about our company's
purpose it seems to me that the if we
want to do something that's purpose
driven it we should probably do
something like this it seems what you're
proposing is violates our purpose and
then go quiet you know it's a little bit
of a little bit shit-stirrer there a
little bit of a posture but but we can
do it in nice ways too but we should
hold our companies accountable if
they're gonna go so far as to say that
they believe in something then we should
we should ask politely for them to
believe in it and if they if we realize
it's all bs and it's just marketing and
it's just something on the website but
really just if you would just shut up
and make your numbers then we have two
options we can leave always an option or
we can choose to be the leaders we wish
we had which is what my preferred option
which is I would rather you build a
really strong Purpose Driven group
within the company and use that why I've
seen this happen where the company has
abandoned its why even though it used to
be true but there are groups inside the
company who still believe in it so if
the senior management isn't following it
you can follow the why and you can use
the companies why to inspire your team
do that be the leader who you wish you
had
start with why and that's how it goes I
think we're done guys okay where am i
nose
people are asking who is helping me in
my background it's my my sister and her
and her son that's my nephew so they're
helping me today usually my niece helps
but my nephew decides to volunteer
thank you very much for helping today
and thank you Sarah filming me also
sorry class oh yes sorry the class sold
out so fast the JumpStart your why so
that so fast
check back to our website next week
simon Sinek calm and i we will announce
more dates for jump start your why fear
not we know a lot of people especially
in these strange times really want to
connect with their why and so we're
gonna we're gonna work hard to get the
kinks out just this first beta test and
then we're gonna offer it as many times
as weekend so stay tuned jump start your
wire will be coming back check back next
week also a shout out to London and
Amsterdam I should be with you this
weekend for the for the mindset tour
clearly we had to postpone I will see
you next year
we have rescheduled the dates I think we
put down the dates I think the dates
have been rescheduled in April next year
thank you thank you thank you for your
patience thank you to Sarah and Matt and
hen for making today happen and next
week I've lost my notes here we go next
week part 4 of start with why there it
is shiny shiny part 4 how to rally those
who believe is the section we'll be
discussing next week on Friday April
24th same time 3 p.m. Eastern
same channel get together with your book
club remember this is not about reading
a book this is about getting together
with each other and having something to
do with each other this is about
community if your book club has
questions please submit them to book
club at simon Sinek come again that's
book club at simon Sinek calm we are
posting all of these live sessions on
youtube if you want to go back and
re-watch any piece of it please feel
free we are posting all of them here
sign up follow us what if the words
subscribe to our youtube channel I never
thought I'd ever say those words
what else do wanna rewrite all of the
book clubs available on YouTube yes we
said that ok I think that's it
thank you everyone for joining I'm gonna
leave you with one thing one exercise to
do in all of these weird kovat times we
our minds very quickly go to all the
things that are hard and difficult no
matter your situation please take out a
piece of paper and write 20 things that
are good about what you're going through
right now I'm choking up I 20 things
that you've learned 20 opportunities
anything 20 good things that are coming
out of this of this this crazy crazy
experience and I guarantee you you'll
make yourself feel better no matter what
take care of yourself take care of
others I will see you next week